انا كنت اصلا عفويا ان نروح للبر و نكشت
ولكن سبحان الله نجد مغرزين فزعه فينا
اصلا يعني مثل ما يقول
احد اساتذتي لو تشرح قلب السعودي تفتح قلب
تقى مكتب فزعه يحبون
الفزعه اسمي خالد عبد العزيز احمد العيسى
ابو عبد العزيز رئيس جمعيه المحترفون
للبحث والانقاذ لي في العمل التطوعي قبل
يعني قبل ما اكون لي فريق هذا كانن في عمل
تطوعي تجاوزت 12 سنه الاصل عملنا مساعده
الناس العالقين المبارزين المنقطعين بنزين
او مبنشر ما يقدر يصلح بنشر معاق يعني
مساعدتهم بجميع الظروف اللي نستطيع عليها
حسب الامكانيات
المتاحه رقمنا معتمد عند العمليات
المشتركه اللي هي 911 احنا كذلك رغم انتشر
الان بوسائل تواصل كل حاله نرسلها نصورها
مثلا نحط رقبنا وننشره نوزع كروت على اللي
نطلعهم الكارات اللي على السياره فيها رقم
اتصالنا عندنا رقم احنا موحد لنا هذا 24
ساعه شخص بيرد عليك رنه الثانيه لابد يرد
عليك لانه م حسينم عندنا افضل اعضائنا
نحطهم في البلاغات لانه راح يتعامل مع
شريحه متنوعه من المجتمع الصغير والكبير
والمراه والشاب والاجنبي فلا بد يكون صدره
وزيع قد يكون الشخص اللي قاعد تتكلم معه
فاقد بعض الشعور قد يرفع صوته عليك يا اخي
وينكم يا اخي يعني ما يعرفك يحسبك موظف في
الدفاع المدني او انك تاخذ فلوس او مقاول
فهذا نقول وسعوا صدوركم عليهم ترى احنا
اللي ق الناس اتصلوا علينا وسعوا صدوركم
عليهم ترى الاجر عظيم
والله انا بكون معك صريح يعني وهذه كل
فرقه الجمد يعني تعاني منها اول الشهر تجد
نشاط الشباب شعله الى نص الشهر الى ثالث
اسبوع بالامكان اخر عش ايام يمكن ت كثير
من الاعضاء يحجمون على المباشرات ما عنده
بنزين تطوع
صح العطاء مطلوب وكن ما عندي شي اعطيه بعض
المرات يا اخي يكون نعرف فلان انه مباشر
مباشر فجاه انقطع ليش ليش فهد ولا محمد
ولا سعد نسال عنه قال والله ان شاء الله
برجعلك مرجعه قويه ما يعني حتى يستحي
يقوللك ولكن اذا ضغطنا على تضح او نزوره
في البيت نعرف ان عنده خلل في سيارته
فوالله يا اخي الفاضل يد الله مع الجماعه
نقول ابشر وين سيارتك نوديها ورشه نعرفها
وتتصلح سيارتها من قطيه من
[موسيقى]
عندنا هذا الطفل اول يوم يداوم في المدرسه
متوسط يعني عمره 12 13 سنه يمكن ابوه جاب
الصبح نزل المدرسه جاء الظهر بياخذه
تقريبا الساعه 12 11 ص 12 انتظر عند الباب
انتظر بين الاطفال ما طلع اتصل فينا
الفريق كلمني مدير المدرسه عندنا طفل مفود
تبحثون معان عليه اطني حثيات الفقد قال
كذا كذا كذا طيب الاطف وون يروحون في
العاده كيف يطلعون اباء اوليا امور في
باصات قال نعم في باصات عندي اعضاء كثيرين
في الجبيل بقياده قائد الجبيل كل منطقه حط
لها قائد كل واحد يركب مع باص كانك راح
توصل من جديد وكل مكان دور اذا في حديقه
في بقاله وين توقع الطفل يروح بقاله حديقه
العاب الحداقه يكون فيها العاب راح
الحديقه قال والله ما في شي قلت خذ نظره
دام هذه الحديقه الوحيده اللي عند الحي يا
سبحان الله اخر باص اخر حديقه
دور دور والتفت لقا في زاويه طايح
ونايم ترت ان تكشت او يعني تروح لرحله مع
من علم اهلك زوجتك اخوانك علم اهلك انك
رايح للسمان علم اهلك رايح كذا الشيء
الثاني معك اجهزه يا اخي خذ معك اجهزه
تعينك الجارمن قيمت 400 ريال يدلك على
الاماكن الجوال شغال قد مكان منطقه ما
فيها شبكه اخذ معاك يا اخي طعام وشراب
يكفيك يا اخي وزياد حط احتمال انك تضيع
يوم تخرز يوم لا تخط لي قد كرتونين صحه ما
تسويلك شي حتى في الشتا يا اخي افحص
المركبه كلها انا بروح بر ماان مراح على
زفلت كل يشوفني بر قد ما اجد احد ابدا قد
اتعطل قبل اصل عند ربعي اللي رايح لهم
اختار رفيقك صح
الرفيق اختار صح شخص اعتمد عليه في
المهمات لا تختار لك شخص مجرد ما تقع في
مشكله
ينهار هذه كثيره حصلت يتركك ويروح
يمشي انا حصل معي موقف الصبح
بلاغ هم ضايعين من امس دخلوا المنطقه تبعد
عن الازفلت 24 كيلو ضاع
غرزه اوول شي غرزه حاولوا يدوسون بنزين
السياره انكسر فيها الشداد حق السير وطاح
طاح السير السياره طفت افتحوا
السوي على المروحه فقط لان فضت البطاريه
في طعس كبير كيلوين تقريبا صعد فوق الطعس
جت شبكه يرفع الجوال اتصل يقطع انا ضايع
كذا المنطقه الفلانيه ارسل رساله اللوكيشن
ولكنها تبعد مسافه كبيره يمكن كيلو ونص
لانه ما اعطاه الدقه المطلوبه المجان بلغ
انا من الدفاع مدن الساعه 11 على طول
لانها الان حاله هلاك وجو حار اقسم بالله
العظيم في السياره 52 معطيني طلعت انا و
وسيارتين على بس وجهه وجهه الجوجل مابس
هذا وصلنا للشارع يعطينا هنا يعني مثلا 24
كيلو دخلنا ونمشي على كذا ما ندري وين
نروح كل ما شفنا جبل او طعس نصعد فوق
ونشوف الله دلنا طبعا المسافه كانت 180
كيلو حوال 200 كيلو اول ما صعدنا شفنا
سياره شي سو اب من بعيد قلنا هذه هي
الزبده كانوا كاتبين وصيتهم للوفاه
كاتبينها في الجوالات لدرجه انذا يقول حق
هذا يا اخي روح موت بعيد عني خليني انا
اموت مرتاح لا موت موتتين وانت
عندي رجال امن ونعم فيهم هم اصلا
احنا
معهم بطريق واحد ما في تقاطع بل فيه توازي
الان 911 اللي هي العمليات المشتركه تتحول
انت لما تتصل 911 خلاص
كل الجهات الامنيه مربوطه على طاوله واحده
زي ما يقولون يتصلون فينا في فريق في عض
في م تعطى هذا رقمه تواصل معه وخبرونا
واحنا في الغالب نستلم نتس على العالق
عيالك معك زوجاتك بيتك حريم اطفال لحالك
عطشان مريض ناخذ منه
وضعه الحالي مريض صاحي على طول ونخلص يا
دفاع مدني خلص الموضوع والامور طيبه جزاكم
الله
خير لو اقول لك شيء اذا جلست يومين ما
طلعت حاله بناتي يبى من زمان ما
طلعت اي والله من زمان هدوء قلتيه هدوء
يسبق العاصفه بعد شوي بلاغه ريله
طريق فيقولون يبا اذا اديت المهمات وجيت
عقب ساعات بعد مره يوم ها يب والله ثم
الله ان وجهك متغير انا قدمت خدمه بس لعل
ادعى لك ذاك يا اخي ان الله يفرج همك
ويسعد قلبك صح ولا لا اجمعك باهلك اجي
توفيق في حياتك كثير والله اي وربي
والله العظيم لا ريان ولا سمعه اجد محبه
الناس يعرفونك في الشارع سياره الانقاذ
هذه الاستيكارات اللي على الببان يدعوا لك
في كل مجلس يا
اخي جانا بلاغ من
شخص اب كل خميس وجمعه او كل جمعه وسبت
ياخذ ولده من احتياجات الخاصه الذهنيه
ياخذه ناصحين لازم يوديه برا
شو يسوي يلعب تكرم بالتراب يفرق الشحنات
ويرجع طبيعي فتره طويله غرزت سياره والولد
حس ان ابوه خايف او ان ابوه متورط صارت له
حاله هستيريه جاني البلاغ قلت يا قروب
الجبيل مجموعه الجبيل طلعونا الرجال ترى
هذا اعلن الله يرحم محمد الرويلي في هذا
الموضوع قال انا جاهز قلت محمد في دوامك
قال يا اخي بيني وبينه 40 كيلو وهو متجه
رايح للرجال قت طمنه قال طمنت العالم اللي
هو ذاك ترى انا جايك في الطريق تطمن
والامور زينه خط الجبيل اللي طالع منه
الاخ محمد الله يرحمه كان في
تحويله يعني مضيقين شوي فهو جاي مضيقين في
الصبات خفف وفي سياره هنا ما انتبه له
بدخلت هنا ضرب طرف
السياره
انقلبت يمكن ثلاث قل او اربع قلبات
والسياره معبيه
بنزين ولعت نار طبعا عندنا مشكله هنا
مشكله ذاك الحين انا انساه قلت يا شباب
توجهوا طلعو لنا الرجال ذاك عالق وقام يدق
عليه قال يا اخي وينكم لكم ساعه ما جيتوني
احنا انشغلنا في هذا حادث خوينا مات شوف
كلنا تذكر الان له اكثر من اربع سنوات
كلنا تذكر هذه الحادثه حادثه محمد
الرويلي حريق وانقلاب رايح يساعد شخص
والله مصر اقول لا تروح طالع من دوام
تعبان في شباب طالعين قال تكفى لا تحر من
الاجر اي والله خليني اسال الله يقبله
بالفردوس الاعلى وكل من دع له وكل من سعه
في هذه الاعمال الخيريه ان الله يحرم وجه
والسامعين عن
النار اللهم امين امين امين يطيك العافيه
العزيز شرفتنا والله يا حبيبي انت والله
تسلم لي يا قلب اب عزيز احتاج منك صفقه بس
على اساس نربط الصوت مع
الصوره صفقه الصفق ع نقدر نربطها مع بعض
بسم الله بس
شك شرفت